hello and welcome to learning about it
with me Lulu today we're going to be
learning about swishin subs or
in-between moves so and in between move
is when your opponent expects you to do
a move like capture piece but instead
you do a different forcing move that
forces your opponent to deal with that
instead all right so black here takes
white's bishop and so white couldn't
recapture the bishop on b2 or you could
play a stunning swish ends ugh C takes
b7 and so here black has the option of
moving his rook to b8 but then after
white just recaptures the bishop White's
position is better here or you can take
on a1 as originally planned but now
after we take and takes White has check
here winning the bishop so he's up a
pawn now and later won the game okay so
today we learned about Intermezzo z-- in
between moves that force your opponent
to deal with something besides what they
were expecting so thanks for learning
about it with me Lulu and make sure to
LIKE and subscribe for more videos